on va revenir sur l'affaire palmate qui
a encore beaucoup fait parler cet été
avec une sortie très remarquée de
l'humoriste en boîte de nuit ou pas
est-ce qu'il y est allé ou pas alors ça
a été le gros sujet de cet été est-ce
que c'était bien lui oui non le
directeur de la discothèque sera avec
nous dans un instant petit récap
regardez le 10 février dernier
l'humoriste Pierre palmat provoquéit un
grave accident de la route sous
l'emprise de stupéfiant c'est un Act
irresponsable en fait de prendre la
drogue aller sur la route plusieurs mois
après le drame l'homme M en examen pour
homicide involontaire et qui était
hospitalisé au CHU de Bordeaux au
service d'adidictologie venait de voir
son contrôle judiciaire s'alléger lui
permettant de sortir librement et cet
été le comédien aurait été aperçu dans
une boîte de nuit bordelaise en train de
s'amuser dans le carré
[Musique]
VIP si ces vidéos ont immédiatement fait
scandale et ont été visionné plusieurs
millions de fois beaucoup doutent de la
véracité de ces images malgré les
témoignages et indiquent qu'elles sont
fausse alors Pierre Palmade est-il
vraiment allé en boîte de nuit cet été
les révélations exclusives du directeur
de la disco è ce soir dans
TPMP Julien Colona est avec nous
directeur d'exploitation d'une
discothèque à Bordeaux salut Julien
salut ça va bien merci d'être là en tout
cas c'est vraiment un amour bravo merci
bravo pour tout j'aime beaucoup alors
bon cette histoire est folle parce que
c'est vrai que tout le monde en a parlé
déjà la question que j'ai envie de vous
poser avant de parler à Julien est-ce
que ça vous dérange vraiment si Pierre
palmat est allé en discothèque ou pas
Kelly moi ça me dérange énormément j'ai
hâte d'avoir la réponse d'accord on va
l' voir dans un instant la réponse
positive je donnerai mon avis bien sûr
ouais vraiment vous ça vous dérange ah
mais ça me dérange
énormément bah c'est dérangeant parce
qu'il a quand même une affaire qui est
en cours il a quand même fait d'ingris
et là on apprend qu'il est en boîte
qu'il est complètement bourré que
peut-être qu'il a pris encore des
stupéfiants en boîte de ce que j'ai
entendu moi ça me dérange franchement
mais je peut même pas penser que de
lui-même être dans une sauce comme ça il
s'amuse à aller danser dans sa tête faut
être complètement éclat si on donne son
avis maintenant alors je vais le donner
pour moi c'est un sombre crétin si fait
ça si fait ça c'est trèsinsulte pas
d'insulte c'est pas une insulte c'est
très gentil dire un moment donné c'est
sûr traite-moi de sombre chrétin dans la
rue tu VO ça va être gentil mais c'est
sû ou oui tu fais des choses abominable
comme il a fait lui tu
teis ah bah dans tous les cas c'est
abominable oui oui non mais voilà donc
vous pour vous c'est c'est inadmissible
c'est inadmissible avant de rner la
réponse de Juli bon sens on a de
l'intelligence et peut-être que sa
drogue lui a cramé les neurones mais je
TR hyper est-ce qu' y en a qui trouvent
pas ça choquant qu'il soit en boîte
voilà Val moi ça me dérange pas qu'il
soit en boîte simplement effectivement
c'est justeb par qu' sait très bien que
de toute façon à l'ortable
et question est-ce c'est pas ça la
question- que ça il droit d'aller en boî
ou pas ilo d'
aller par lo on dit selon nous oui la
morale pour moi pour moi c'est un peu la
même chose que le prisonnier tout à
l'heure qui est avec sa piscine c'est
qu' un moment donné il y a des règles tu
as aussi le droit quand même de prendre
un petit peu de bon temps ce qui serait
choquant attends attends ce qui serait
choquant ce qui serait choquant c'est
qu'il prenne le volant il est pas la loi
le
juge c'est ce que je dis que jeou que je
dis on parle on te parle de bon sens non
mais il a Jacques ça le choque pas non
ça me choque pas ça me choque pas il
suit il suit des soins actuellement il a
c'est terrible ce qu'il a fait c'est
horrible il est pas excusable il l'a dit
lui-même ça ça on le JAMA voilà donc
pour toi il aurait pas dû attendre un
petit peu pour la dcence envers la
famille de se comporter de manière
discrète de toute
façonbut depuis le début
malheureusement tout est une tragédie
dans cette affaire pour moi je pense que
pour la famille c'est insupportable de
le voir lui en train de
faire BB Mor c'est la première victime
voilà en plus pour le conducteur qui
était en face absolument mais maintenant
on parle juste de la boîte de nuit il
est autorisé par le juge oui bah il sort
il a le droit de le faire rien de
l'interdit après moralement moi
personnellement ça me choque pas vraon
le problème c'est la justice en fait
alors dès le début parce que s'il est en
boîte là c'est parce que la justice lui
a dit oui tu as le droit d'aller en
boîte la justice lui a dit oui tu as le
droit de conduire sous stupéfiant oui tu
as le droit de cartonner une voiture en
face de toi et tuer un bébé qui était
dans le ventre de sa maman oui tu as le
droit oui reprends des stupéfiants
reprends de l'alcool nous on te laisse
tu as le droit oui oui pour l'instant on
va savoir s'il est talent ou pas mais
parce que comme ça fait ça fait un buz
énorme ce qui é
wir ça te dérange bien sûr que ça me
dérange et surtout
que c'est Michel he c'est bien ça
julienich pardon Julien excusez-moi
Julien Michel c'est mon
cousin mais il va passer si tu veux tout
à l'heure sur consci
Richard autant pour moi autant pour moi
l'esprit de conscience il l à ce momentl
vous qui êtes patron de boîte vous savez
que ça fait énormément de bruit non mais
luii il est pas responsable non non mais
on est bien d'accord mais je vais finir
tu verras qu'il sera toujours pas
responsable euh pour pour pour le coup
quand vous voyez arriver ce monsieur
est-ce que vous avez pas avec les videur
en disant vous vous rentrez pas attendez
attendez pour l'instant on n'est pas là
il va nous dire s'il est allé ou pas
voilà si ça vous dérange vous si
vraiment il est allé en boîte de nuit
oui il y a la loi il a le droit l'esprit
de la loi moi je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse en fait il y a un truc de
provocation d'impunité je fais ce que je
veux comme je veux j'emmerde tout le
mondeit il était au bout du rouleau il
s'est dit ses potes l'ont chauffé ils
l'ont dit il faut que tu sortes ouais
mais voilà à ce moment-là ça veut dire
que ça veut dire que pour moi alors à ce
moment-là c'est encore un esprit très
malade et très perturbé pas bah il doit
pas être bien non plus he pierre arrivé
voyz pas il peê pas la forme enfin
suffisamment pour aller en boite alors
oui mais Pascal moi je suis d'accord
avec geréraline c'est un problème
d'abord d'image c'est l'image qu' envoyé
maintenant avec les réseaux soci pi il
son fout total maintenant PAL pense son
fout total maintenant l'image là je vais
dire je pense que contrôle judiciaire
avait été allégé il avait le droit pas
de conduire pas de rentrer en contact
avec les victimes pas drogue évidemment
mais il avait le droit d'aller en boîte
mais c'est vrai que le message envoyé et
je suis pas sûr que son avocat soit très
content qu' pour moi la dessence et la
morale c'est qu'il n'aille pas en boîte
il reste chez lui il reste à l'hôpital
ou alors chez lui il ne sort pas il se
montre pas en public c'est ind descent
les victimes vont mal elles se
reconstruisent très timidement j'ai eu
leur avocat aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile pour tous heureusement le
conducteur est sorti de l'hôpital mais
c'est très dur de se reconstruire non il
n'a pas droit moralement d'aller en
boîte Alex après jeis vous donner la
réponse he ce qu'il est allé ou pas oui
je suis entièrement d'accord il tu as
des gens il y a un bébé qui est mort il
y a des gens qui peuvent plus danser
pour le coup et lui il va danser donc
c'est c'est ça que je trouve moi
extrêmement choquant et j'ai Hâ d'avoir
la réponse du Grand schtrou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ou attends alors regardez la vidéo la
vidéo qui a circulé la boîte s'appelle
l'ultra club c'est la plus grande
discothèque friendly de Bordeaux là où
il est depuis qu'il a quitté la région
par ex par qu'il est à Bordeaux alors
voilà il y a cette vidéo qui a circulé
est-ce qu'elle est récente ou pas est-ce
que c'ta vrai pierre Palm a dit qu'il
était pas en boîte et d'ailleurs voilà
ce c'est ce qu' a dit Julien
[Musique]
également dans les
toilettes
[Musique]
alors
Julien il est con la tachche blanche là
ouis que j'ai déjà vu en boîte de nuit
d'ailleurs je vais jamais en boî de
[Applaudissements]
nuit pas vu boire par contre parce que
pour le coup je vois pas il vois pas
mais bon il nous en parlera aprèsinqu on
s'occupera de ton cas après je te
remercie Julien Julien donc Julien
Pierre et et et vous vous avez dit qu'il
était pas allé dans cette boîte donc
qu'est-ce qu' parce que vous avez dit
qu'il était pas allé que c'était en fait
c'était pas là c'était pas là c'était
pas maintenant c'était avant voilà
est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas alors euh
j'été contacté dès le dimanche matin à
partir de 9h on débauche à 8h du matin
j'ai eu 98 appel de de tout ce qui est
journalis tout ça ou bon moi à la base
je suis prend la discrétion de mes
clients la première chose que j'ai dit
c'était qu'il était pas présent en
discothèque bien sûr parce que ouais bon
on narrêtait pas de t'appeler tu as dit
voilà moi je je vais pas le balancer
voilà et bon tu VO je te dis je
comprends on j'aurais dit la même chose
que toi je te jure Julien on t'appelle
on dit le gars ça se fait pas je veux
dire franchement à la limite je
comprends que tu l'ai fait je comprends
que tu dit qu'il y est pas allé qu' pas
allé qu'il était pas allé parce que
franchement ça se fait pas tu aurais dit
oui à tout le monde oui il était hier là
hier soir balance et après donc tu étais
obligé de dire qu'il était pas et tu
sais Cyril j'aurais dit j'aurais dit bah
oui il était là et tout on aurait dit tu
fais le buzz sur ça tu fais toi tu tes
mis souvent au milieu de de de tous ces
déchaînements médiatiques
maisou moi je suis un commerçant a 21
salariés
euh j'ai Monsieur Pierre Palma de K de
Bordeaux qui était venu auparavant dans
la discothèque avant avant avant
leouis voilà moi je il y a il y a le
ministre de la Justice comme ça il faut
aller voir notre
ami
hein tu le connais je le connais oui
ouaison qu'il y a une petite
alors à
20h49 il est il est venu dans la boîte
ouais il est venu dans la boîte donc tu
avais menti au départ ENF tu l'as
couvert au dép menti j'ai j'ai voilà mes
clients il y a pas à savoir s'ils
étaient là s' étaaiit pas là moi quand
il m'appelle un mec il me dit est-ce que
non non parce qu'il veut prendre la
parole lui il est
outré il a bien fait de couvir vouis lui
poser une question ah d'cord il
on t'a dit tout de suite a perd pas à
l'entrée ou bien tu le savais pas non
j'étais devant j'étais devant tu laisses
rentrer pas toi de dire sil doit aller
en boî ou pas il a réglé son entrée il a
réglé s bien
sentr pierre Palm tu l'as pas fait tu
l'as fait payer
l'entre parti moi mais je pas te faire
payer vous avez fait un selfie avec lui
vous avez posté un selfie avec lui le
dimanche puis vous l'avez retiré donc là
vous avez avoué à tout le monde est venu
pourquoi vous avez retiré le self une
St du tout des bêtis du tout pourquo je
dis des btises parce que c'était une
ancienne story vous dit des bêtises vous
êtes un journaliste qui vous êtes un
journaliste qui très mal c'est la
première fois qu'il est venu voilà tout
à fait voilà donc et toi la deux fois ça
été rajouté c'est pas la même police de
texte il est habillé en blanc suivez vos
dossiers non mais en plus en plus en
plus je te dis un autre truc voilà non
mais je te dis un autre truc il vient de
te le dire qu'il est venu donc pourquoi
il va te mentir sur ça
mais ce qui est incroyable c'est qu'il a
menti tout ce tempsl Cyril qui bah lui
mais il a le droit et alors il a pas dro
ça fait ça fait des années que
toutement c'est vrai attends franchement
ouais me non mais attends il pas il y a
des journalistes qui l'appellent le
dimanche matin franchement moi j'aurais
pas aimé que Julien dise oui il était là
hier soir et qui donne tous les détails
il a il l'a dit non au départ c'est
normal et puis là ça a fait un buzz
négatif pour lui parce que les gens on
dit ouais il a menti il est venu il
vient rétablir la vérité je comprends
tout à fait le mec il se retrouve dans
une sauce dans laquelle il a rien à voir
alors ilaccepte pas dès le départ comme
client mais à partir du moment où vous
l'acceptez c'est normal de pas le dire
pourquoac pas je pouvais pas madame je
pouvais pas moi je suis je suis un
commerçant je lui dirais quoi non et je
je cautionne pas ce qu'il a fait il y a
la famille tout ça je conne pas du tout
ce qu'il a fait moi moralement c'est pas
le problème c'est que JEI demander s'il
avait consommé ouais vous avez il a
consommer de l'alcool ou pas de verr
d'alcool même pas la bouteille rien il
était au VIP tout façon en plus au VIP
ça s'est passé comment à la sortie après
l'ouais je accacompagné ouais ouis je
suis resté devant avec lui pris une
voiture un
ouais
un parce que pour CP non mais parce que
je dis ça cyil parce que pour le coup
judiciairement c'est intéressant si on
apprend ce soir que il a pris le volant
n on a enfin les images ont été montr
quand il sortait il est pas monté il est
monté effectivement dans un taxi on a vu
les images PAL volant moi je considère
que vous n'avez pas menti je considère
que vous l'avez protégé je l'ai protégé
je trouve ça très bien
voilà c'est normal voilà donc Alex gout
tu tu le protèges ah oui là merci
beaucoup mais c'est vrai voilà c'est
ça pe poser une question à Jacques tu l'
il l'a protégé c'est normal tout est
normal pierre Palm il danse c'est normal
il boit c'est normal il fait ce qu'il
veut stupéfiant c'est normal si c'était
ton petit garçon de 5 ans qui serait
resté 3 mois à l'hôpital tu aurais dit
c'est normal que Pierre Palma il all
danser si il en avait tué l'enfant dans
le ventre de ta femme tuaurais dit c'est
normal que pi c'est normal qu'il
protègemi htement mais oui mais parce
que vous êtes dans l'idée que dans
l'émotion dans cette mais oui bien sûr
est-ce que tu sais par non non mais je
vais te répondre je vais te répondre
est-ce que tu sais que sa
notoriété risque de lui coûter bien plus
que s'il avait été quelqu'un d' pas
connu pour exactement les mêmes faits
non mais alors dans ce cas-là on va vers
une justice où il y a une automaticité
c'est-à-dire que il a fait ce qu'il a
fait et ça coûte je sais pas moi 5 ans 6
ans 7 ans 8 ans aujourd'hui la justice
elle est à l'appréciation du juge et en
fonction de comment va se dérou
le procès figure-toi que sa notoriété
c'est certain ça va lui coûter bien plus
que s'il avait pas été connu par exemple
a eu je vais te dire par exemple est-ce
que tu sais que dans le cas d'un
accident de voiture il y a pas y a
jamais de perquisition au domicile il a
été perquisitionné son domicile a été
perquné il y a des éléments matériels
humains qui sont mis sur cette affaire
qui sont bien plus importants que pour
des faits similaire avec quelqu'un qui
n'est pas connu sans compter les
faabulations quand on dit qu'il était
pédophile pour 3 jours après voilà
touteç sa carrière est terminée je veux
dire évidemment et encore une fois la
victime c'est d'abord le
bébé oui non mais là on est quand même
d'une manche faétude incroyable envers
Pierre Palmade mais qu'est-ce que tu as
non mais franchement je trouve que
Jacques cardose là qu'est-ce qu'il a
estce que il défend les gens qui vont
être jugés pour potentiellement pour
homicide et blessures involontaires
c'est quand même très grave c'est trè
bah si vous dites qu'il a le droit
d'aller en boîte que si que ça droiter
en BO il un juge a décidé avant sa
notoriété vous dites que sa notoriété va
lui causer bien des troubles c'est
l'inverse c'est l'inverse tu sais
pourquoi parce que l'enquête l'enquête
montre d'ors et déjà Gill l'enquête
montre d'ors et déjà que les moyens qui
ont été mis en place sont bien plus
importants que si c'était quelqu'un de
pas tout il y a pas de perquisition aprs
il y a eu une perquisition le lendemain
à son domicile toute la nuit et Cera non
mais ce sont des choses oui oui oui je
je voulais répondre à r Je je l'ai pas
protégé je l'urai fait pour tout le
monde
non mais moi j'ai rien sur le fait que
tu la protèges c'est ton métier c'est
ton business il vient n'importe qu'il
vient le monde de la nuit c'est le monde
de la nuit ici c'est on fait comme tu as
été pro Palma dit vient s'il vient c'est
qu'il est en liberté il est pas s'est
pas sauvé d'une prison il te demande de
la consommation
d'alcool
pas pouri les caméras de surveillance es
sont sorties ah ça alors ça a été pris
dans
l'entrée de la discothèque ouais alors
ah il y a les retours dans l'entrée de
la discothèque ça c'est le but des
caméras de surveillance bon et donc là
alors donc toi tu avais dit au départ
qu'il était jamais venu voilà c'est
totalement faux il n'était pas chez nous
ce weekend il est déjà venu mais la
vidéo date de l'avant covid depuis on a
fait des travaux on peut se rendre
compte en comparant avec les images qui
ét filmé mais tu nous dis aujourd'hui il
est venu il est venu ouais et je voulais
je voulais dire aussi parce qu'il a
Monsieur Verdes il a contacté l'avocate
à à la famille mais
le pierre palmad il a fait des des T
test d'urine dès le lendemain ou le
lundi je sais pas quoi et qui ont été
révélés où il y avait pas il y avait pas
de drogue dans dans le parce qu' y avait
comment il
s'appelle olive olive là ouis voilà
ouais c'est une boîte de drogué c'est
une boî de tout ça ouais voilà ouais he
d'accord ok ouais merci bon très bien
merci Julien d'être venu et on t'enverra
Alex dans la boîte